who felt hands off okay pottsy didn't
felt they had a good answer to this
question justify why an expert system
was its own to be unsuitable or an
inappropriate solution to this problem
hands off did anyone know if you're
confident I have good memory or
recollection at all okay here's his wife
everyone should put up their hands for
this even looking at it right now
because like in the previous question
this is a textbook question you didn't
need to know anything about the
situation to be able to answer this
question okay what's the difference
functionally between ecosystem and what
Patman isn't an artificial neural
network okay I know there's the
difference between learning and not
learning okay but I'm thinking about how
does how do we as like a developer we're
trying to choose what solution we should
pick should I pick an extra assistant or
should I pick an artificial neural
network what's the main difference in
how they're made or constructed or
designed
I've got I've got an expert system right
here okay uh you know in this part or
the previous page this is basically an
expert system right it's a set of rules
these have been determined by an expert
and there's logic that goes underneath
one and you go from one step to another
and you go through very methodically you
back with a food chain or whatever okay
and then you come to a conclusion okay
the decision this is an excellent system
what rules and what logic would you
write if you're trying to do something
like this when what you're trying to
determine is whether there are abnormal
cells
it was slighted or not yeah that's right
see when you when you go back to all of
those the the rules that were in the
what was it is that this security
license yeah the rules are what we call
an expert system has well-defined rules
with clear logic okay there's lots off
if this then that
okay this flows onto this goes on to
that right and it's a very it's a very
step-by-step kind of process okay but
you can see from reading this right
there's a lot of intuition involved and
experience involved and be able to
determine what what's a nasty I'm sly
and what's not right it's so tricky that
you can see they miss a lot of them
right it's not really simple like up you
just go through the checklist and if it
meets these criteria yes it has
precancerous cells okay it's more
complex than that it's more nuanced than
that okay so why was so here's the
question why is an expert system
unsuitable everyone talked about the
learning aspect okay which is not really
the point okay
I think out of out of two I was tempted
to give you one if you explain that well
but it really was not the point okay
because if it was about learning
an expert system can still if you can
programmer well if the if the rules are
clear the logic is clear it would just
take you longer to design it okay but it
won't necessarily be unsuitable or
inappropriate like no we can't possibly
use an extra system for this situation
okay it's that the nature of the problem
and this is Laurie mentioned under
decision consciousness women dealt with
these clients if these categories of
decision support systems it's that which
led to the problem okay and basically
your land into marks or most of you did
it okay so that's why
and so you justified it by saying look
apart from the whole murder thing expert
systems and this is sorry artificial
neural networks they get programmed in
vastly different ways okay okay so let
me try and finish up another critically
Wow I was so mean sorry
critically evaluate the use of this
neural network system compared to the
previous manual system where trade
pathologists the rule would manually
check each slide okay all right so I for
six marks I was looking for not just six
aspects but were were you evaluating in
a in a sophisticated way okay so let me
show you I have any points that I have I
had a lot of words okay so see if you
can keep up okay
let's start by saying if I try to
evaluate I'm gonna try and compare these
two things
okay evaluates a really higher order HSE
keyword okay so it includes compare and
contrast with it right so give me some
disadvantages of the existing system
your system
give me a nice obvious one start again I
can't tie the leg oh yeah it's um it's
costly with regard to time and labor a
better way to say is money really
because money translates to effort okay
so if you want labor you have to spend
money okay time is money
it's just money isn't it okay anyway it
costs a lot it's expensive right
actually time isn't quite money here
because the time aspect turns out to be
crucial okay because to train us I told
you our technician to do this takes
years right where is the unofficial new
network what's it strained you don't
have to retrain a new one and you wanted
a new one when you know your actual ones
get old and you know retiring that kind
of thing okay so here's my first
disadvantage another one it's a it's a
statistic a really bad one in nautical
we already drew attention to it
yeah the error rates atrocious right the
error rate is very high okay 10 to 30
percent from anything that's a massive
proportion okay so these are
disadvantages of the manual system so
these are reasons why later on when I do
my evaluation I'm gonna say yeah the new
network is very justified okay okay now
let's start talking about the the
artificial neural network okay and let's
talk about its pros and it's cons
advantages now let's skip the ones which
are kind of just the opposite of this
okay so we can already say accuracy
right it can become more accurate and
also we can say speed of training right
because once you've got a trained you
know it'll work for however long okay
what other kinds of managers can you
think of electronic system versus the
humans
ah good okay so you can get this and
this is this doesn't just apply to
artificial neural networks it's a it's a
the comparison is between humans and an
electronic decision support system of
some kind okay so we did a whole list of
these right so accessibility
patna can run 24 hours a day right it
can just keep on going anyone can get to
it in time you're not restricted to when
these cytologists are available okay so
accessibility we talked about the
problem of retirements if it ever really
experienced I told you it has to retire
so what's the advantage of an artificial
neural network with regard to that yeah
that's right you know it never it never
gets old so how we say that it's more
than where we use it's everlasting
everlasting bye-bye shanell or something
oh it sounds like a perfect so it's it's
we actually had a word for this
something like that
okay yeah so you don't have the you
don't have the retraining cycle that's a
problem okay if anything just gets
better and better with time it's like
why okay what other advantages have we
got
so this is about it preserves the expert
knowledge base okay and I think
consistency is a really important word
okay so the system ought to be able to
do the same things over and over again
okay and it's not going to miss parts of
like oh I didn't see this part of the
slide because I was hired because I'm a
human being
okay the system is going to be
methodical and consistent in the way
that looks across every single slide in
the same way okay all right now it
wasn't a good critically evaluate unless
you told me that the artificial New York
had problems too okay so what were some
of its weaknesses yeah that's right so
there's an initial outlays the best way
to say it which far outstrips you know
the cost of employing someone they're
dead that that cost is gonna add up over
a long time okay
but this sister it starts off and it's
you know not hundreds and thousands it's
millions of dollars just to get the
thing working
okay versus say a few hundred thousand
dollars to train someone that haven't
actually get a few years of experience
okay so there's that issue what else
what are the disadvantages we are I'm
not gonna show you a we've looked at
jaws before right so jobs is always kind
of a both aimed right because you'll
you'll destroy jobs and you'll create
new ones okay so I'm not going to say
that explicitly and also I'm trying to
connect it to look at the question I'm
trying to compare it to the previous
manual system the use of the system so
this isn't just a a blanket sort of
social ethical issues of all clients
it's a it's about okay how well will
this function how well it's do its job
right it's an operational feasibility
questions if you like sorry said again I
get okay so yeah okay so erroneous
various data might lead to poor learning
oh I remember these okay and he's a big
one right it's different to the expert
system if you want to ask an expert
system okay why is it that you decided
why is it that you decided to give you
know such-and-such a guy a security
license okay how would the expert system
respond to you number one what's the
party Exorcist in the war in response
the explanation mechanism okay and what
is the explanation mechanism going to do
bingo good it's gonna go through these
rules okay I'm gonna say look I'll tell
you exactly why I came on the license
okay because you told me you should I
should give a license if I do this in
this well I checked this miss and that's
let me do this and this and go through
everything it'll tell you all the rules
it'll tell you all the data which
activate those rules and so on okay
now same scenario you go to your
artificial network right new network and
you said okay tell me why you diagnose
this patient as having a positive result
for precancerous cells and the
artificial neural network will reply and
say yeah done or basically you're right
it's like well experience I think I saw
the pattern that I've seen before I
think that was the pattern you know
there's not there is no explanation
mechanism and an artificial new record
doesn't have one okay and the design is
gonna say the design of the new network
will say cuz cuz I trained it and you
know it just did its thing so that's a
major problem when you're thinking about
okay the use of a neural network in a
medical kind of area well any time where
you want an explanation
okay so it's unable to explain
okay no I wasn't looking for a simple
one two three four five six to get your
six marks okay like I said I was looking
at the sophistication of your answer in
particularly did you get that right now
after I've got all this I'm going to
evaluate what judgment would you make I
think the new networks the way to go
okay
it does have significant disadvantages
okay but especially when you have a look
at the kinds of disadvantage of the
previous system have versus these
advantages it's um it's a pretty
overwhelming choice if you can make it
work okay so there's my evaluation I
deliver it on the basis of all these
points that I've raised okay okay